So now we've found the balance after one year for Grant's account and the
balance after two years. What we're going to do now is something that we
haven't really done in this course yet. I'm going to ask you to make a
hypothesis. This just means that you're going to come up with an idea and we'll
see if it's right pretty soon. This is something that mathematicians do all the
time. They look at examples, look for a pattern, guess what the pattern might
mean, and then test their guess to see if it's right. If it's wrong, it's not a
big deal. They try again with a new guess. So the question I have for you is,
what does the two here mean? Where does it come from, and what does it stand
for? Think about what might be going on, in general, with these equations. And
see if you can predict the pattern without working anything out. Write your
guess in this box. Just so you know, this is not going to be graded.